-Our guest tonight was the mayor
of South Bend, Indiana,
and a presidential candidate
He's currently the United States
secretary of Transportation.
Please welcome back to the sho
Secretary Pete Buttigieg.
Hello!
How are you, Secretary?!
-Hey, good to see you.
I'm doing well, thanks.
-I guess that's the first thin
I want to ask you,
is how are you adjusting
to the new title?
People knew you, obviously
as Mayor Pete for a long time.
How is Secretary Buttigieg
fitting you?
You know, they say,
"Once a major, always a mayor,
so I'm always happy
to answer to "Mayor Pete,"
but I'm certainly excited
to be the secretary.
-You got off to a sort of
inauspicious start,
in that you had to quarantin
after being exposed.
How was quarantine for you
Was it as difficult
as it's been for many people
-You know, I didn't love it,
but I'm glad to be
on the other side of it.
This morning, I took the dog
out for a walk before breakfas
and it just felt,
even though it was gray and icy,
it felt fantastic just
to be outdoors again.
And, obviously, you know, we'r
urging people to be careful,
to take every safety measure
and it was important to me
to make sure we're
practicing what we preach.
-And so this was your firs
Oval Office meeting.
Obviously, you couldn't
be there in person,
-[ Laughs ]
-so you were wheeled in
on a big-screen TV.
[ Laughter ]
How was that as an experience?
-Yeah, I mean, you know,
like most Americans, right
I've always wondered what it's
like inside the Oval Office.
And, the first time in my life
I'm actually invited
to go into the Oval Office
for a meeting
and it's in like
this disembodied form, right
Coming in on a TV cart by Zoom
So, basically,
the most 2021 thing
that could possibly happen
but it was a good meeting.
White House did a great jo
of making it possible
for me to participate.
We were talking with senator
from both parties
about how important it is
to build up our infrastructure
and I'm glad I could be there,
even if it had to be
in that way.
-You mentioned infrastructur
and the previous administratio
sort of was always promising
an infrastructure week
that never came.
Based on that, I'm wondering
what was the state
of the department
or how are you finding
the state of the departmen
in your early days of the job?
-You know, the department ha
about 55,000 employees
and they're
doing fantastic work,
but we do need to make sure that
we're actually putting our money
where our mouth is
on infrastructure.
There's been a lot of talk
about it for years and years
Now, we've actually got
to do something
and I think we have
a chance to do it.
It's a huge priority
for President Biden.
It's something most American
from both parties want us to d
and we've just got to make sur
Washington actually responds
It's a big part of what I feel
I'm here to do.
-President Biden is proposin
billions of dollars
in transportation aid
in this COVID relief package
Why is money for transportatio
so important,
in a time of a pandemic,
where maybe people think
the money
could be better spent elsewhere?
-Right, so I think a lot
of people are asking,
"Why would you put transit
funding into a bill
that's about COVID relief?
And let's be clear -- the reason
this bill is so urgent is
because it's about getting
relief to Americans.
It's about getting shots
in arms.
But transit and transportation
is part of that.
I mean, how are people
supposed to get their shots,
if transit agencies
around the country are
at risk of shutting down
or cutting their routes
even further,
if they don't get immediat
financial relief?
So this package really is
about the things
that cannot wait,
that have to happen right away
and it's why
it's the top priority
of the president
and the administration.
Look, most Americans
want this to happen,
Americans from both parties.
We just got to make sure
Congress actually responds
-I think a lot of people
maybe fail to see
how transportation connect
to all different parts
of our political life.
One other thing it touches
is climate change.
Do you feel, in your position,
that there's a future
for transportation
in this company, that maybe --
in this country -- excuse me -
that maybe takes climate chang
more into account
with what the future is?
-Absolutely.
We have to.
There's no other choice.
Look, the biggest contributo
of greenhouse gases
in the U.S. economy
is the transportation sector
But that means
the transportation sector
could actually be the bigges
part of the solution,
and we're seeing that happen
in every different form
of transportation.
We've got to support it.
I mean, you look,
to take one example,
at electric vehicles.
More and more,
we're seeing automakers,
including the classic longtime
automakers out of Detroit,
coming up with ideas
for electric vehicles
and committing to them
and developing them
and selling them as we speak
Now, of course, simultaneously
we've got to make sure not onl
that our cars are greener,
but that people have
alternatives to driving,
that we have
good subway systems,
that we have good trains
in this country.
I don't know why Americans
should be expected to settle
for fewer options
for passenger rail
than people who live in Chin
or Britain or Italy.
We should be the best
in all of these fields,
and that's what we're callin
on Congress to help us do.
-Be honest -- how excited
does the president get
when you start talking
about trains?
Like when high-speed rail
comes up,
is it a noticeable change
in his demeanor?
-I mean, you know, he famously
loves passenger rail,
so I thought I would be
the biggest passenger rail
enthusiast around,
but I think
I'll be a close second,
but always second place
in this administration.
He's all over this.
And, again,
I think, not just
as a personal fondness,
but an understanding
that so many of the things
this administration's
here to do.
Yes, climate,
but also creating jobs,
delivering equity
in this country.
These are some of the things
that are at stake
in the choices we make
about our trains, planes,
automobiles, ships, and more
-Racial inequality
is something else
that is affected,
you know, very much
by access to things like
public transportation.
Is that something that's sort of
near the front of your lis
as well?
Although, I am mentioning
a lot of things
that would be at the front
of your list, I understand
-Yeah, but we've got to do
all these things at once -
safety, climate, equity,
and jobs.
And, yes,
when it comes to equity,
racial equity
is a huge part of that.
Look, I know, when you're
thinking about, you know,
racial justice in this country
Department of Transportation
may not be the first thing
to pop into your mind,
but think about the
Montgomery Bus Boycott.
Think about Rosa Parks.
The history of civil right
in this country
has always been
very closely tied
to the question of equity
in transit and transportation.
And it's not just about,
you know, what neighborhoods
get the subway stop or wha
communities get the investment
but also the fact that, frankly,
in this country,
we have a legacy
of investments happening
at the expense
of communities of color.
So many Black neighborhoods,
for example,
that were sometimes destroye
or literally cut in two
by a highway project
going through them.
That's something that
has happened in this country
and not just in the distan
past, but in very recent memory.
And it's something we could fi
and do something about,
if we have racial equity in mind
as we make the next set
of transportation decision
for this country.